le 20e printemps de bourges vient de
s'achever ce festival de musique rock a
vu défiler une pléiade de chanteurs qui
ont célébré tout à fait dignement cet
anniversaire car c'est bien connu on n'a
pas tous les jours 20 ans reportage
louis carzou et axel charles mais sans
se les 20 ans du printemps c'est
toujours comme ça ça vient et sa samba
et ça reviendra à bourges
quels sont mes amis devenus
j'avais deux cyprès tenue
il est temps
de la musique de précieux présents et
plein de monde jusqu'aux cousine un peu
éloigné cet anniversaire méritait
vraiment la photo d'autant plus que dans
le rôle du tonton qui prolonge la fête
avec ses drôles de chansons renault
s'est emparée des mots et des notes de
monsieur brassens de quoi souffler
toutes et tous jusqu'au bout j'y j'ai
croqué dans son corsage
c'est comme ça comment comment peut-on
ne pas aimer brassens et ça serait
presque je serais étonné je sais pas si
c'est prétentieux de dire ça mais gens
qui viennent écouter mes chansons et qui
les aiment système pas brassens et
quelque chose d'incohérent quoi donc pas
je me compare à bassens en aucun cas
mais moi j'aime tellement brassens il
m'a tellement guider et m a tellement
émerveillé pendant toute sa vie c'est
vraiment c'est le moi je suis le limbe
l'élève lui c'est le grand maître quoi
avec des fleurs comme ça les habitudes
de gauche vont vraiment finir par croire
à la semaine des 4,5 euros